as russian forces invaded ukraine
western countries responded with a
different kind of weapon we're living in
a world
where the tools of war are actually
economic and trade weapons canada the us
and europe announcing a slew of
sanctions measures that are tougher than
anything we've ever seen before as far
as russia is concerned but this hedge
fund manager and high profile kremlin
critic says the measures still fall
short what is fundamentally upsetting to
vladimir putin is going after his own
money
and what all the sanctions programs so
far missing is going after his own money
putin's own money he says is controlled
by around 50 russian oligarchs whose
assets were left untouched
and even the sanctions targeting
russia's economy are less potent now
than they were after its annexation of
crimea in 2014.
in the seven years since putin has only
furthered russia's foreign reserves and
resilience so it's less dependent on the
us dollar it's less dependent on oil
revenues because the other thing that
it's done is actually pivot to the east
from crude oil to computer chips russia
now does more business with china and
eurasian nations it's also creating its
own international payment system in case
it gets cut off from swift germany and
italy in particular are reportedly
resisting kicking russia out of the
international banking system that's seen
as a nuclear option carrying significant
economic consequences especially for
nations that rely on russian oil europe
sucks on russian gas like a crackhead on
a pipe and how does a junkie sanction
its dealer
it's very very difficult western leaders
insist the swift option is still on the
table but the latest sanctions come too
late for the people of ukraine
jeff semple global news